okay now the reality is again i'm in
favor of mass scoring in close quarters
i'm not anti-mass scoring but mass
mandates have not proved to be a
in any way a problem solver for a wide
variety of countries
germany has a mass mandate italy has a
mass mandate
there are mass mandates all over the
world okay and in many countries with
the mass mandate you can see the charts
the mass
the rates of covert are here there's a
mass man that goes into place here it
goes like this for a while and
it just spikes during the winter just
like a second wave
right and here's the reality about
wearing masks
mask wearing is good for protecting
other people apparently apparently this
is what we are told
okay we have not a lot of evidence to
disprove that at this point but
it is not true that wearing a mask is
likely to protect you unless you are
wearing like the finest highest grade
caliber of medical mask
this is not according to me this is
according to the new york times okay so
before the new york times checks me for
reading the new york times this is a new
york times story
okay gina colada writing researchers in
denmark reported on wednesday that
surgical masks
did not protect the wearer against
infection with the coronavirus in a
large randomized clinical trial
the findings conflicts with those from a
number of other studies experts said and
is not likely to alter public health
recommendations in the united states now
when they say there are a number of
other studies no what the other studies
show
is they take a mask and then they take
an aerosol and they spray the aerosol at
the mask
okay which is not useful this is like
saying that you did a study
in ideal conditions in ideal conditions
and the mask was somewhat more
protective than if you were not wearing
a mask
well guess what life is not in ideal
conditions there's a famous joke
about economists right that economists
live in sort of a fantasy world
of people who don't really exist where
you have two economists
on a desert island and they're trying to
figure out how to get off the desert
island
and one economist turns to the other
economist and says assume a boat
right because they live in a world of
theoretical construct
okay when it comes to mask wearing it is
a theoretical construct that everyone is
going to properly fit a mask to their
face and wear properly they actually
have courses in medical school for how
to properly don
personal protective equipment random joe
over here who just picked up
a cloth face mask from a street corner
by the gas station
the chances that he's properly donning
his mask and treating it well are very
very low okay so what does that mean
doesn't mean you shouldn't wear a mask
in close contact you should because
again if you sneeze
and you're wearing a mask as logic would
suggest
your sneeze is at least somewhat more
contained than it would be if you're not
wearing a mask
however the evidence suggests that for
the vast majority of people meeting
nearly everybody
who is wearing the same mask all day
putting it in their pocket taking it out
putting it back on their face
messing around with their mask that the
chances that you're going to be
prevented from getting coveted by
wearing a mask that is not a k
that is not an n95 are actually quite
low the study is published in the annals
of internal medicine
it did not contradict growing evidence
that mass can prevent transmission of
the virus from the wearer to others but
the conclusion is at odds with the view
that masks also protect the wearers a
position endorsed just last week by the
cdc
critics were quick to note the study's
limitations you can see how the new york
times is desperately trying to spin away
from this study
it is the only mass study done in real
world conditions and they're trying to
spin away from the conclusions
critics were quick to note the study's
limitations among them the design
depended heavily on participants
reporting their own test results and
behavior
at a time when both mass scoring and
infection were rare in denmark so in
other words we're not going to trust the
study
because some people may have lied about
how often they were wearing masks what
do you think happens in real life
do you think people always tell the
truth or anything what do you think is
more likely to be an accurate study of
human behavior
an actual study of human behavior or you
take a mask in a in a lab and then you
fire aerosol spray at it
dr anthony fauci of the nia id
advocates a national mass mandate as now
does joe biden
from early april to early june
researchers at the university of
copenhagen recruited 6 000 participants
who'd been tested beforehand to make
sure they didn't have covet
half were given surgical masks and told
to wear them when leaving their homes
others were told not to wear masks in
public
about 4 800 participants completed the
study the researchers had hoped that
masks would cut the infection rate by
half among wearers instead
42 people in the masking group about 1.8
percent got infected
compared with 53 in the unmasked group
or about 2.1 percent
that difference is not statistically
significant dr medicalgar
a professor of medical decision making
at university of oslo says the study
showed although there might be a
symbolic effect
the effect of wearing a mask does not
substantially reduce risk for wearers
okay that is obviously
a uh a a problematic outcome for people
who are insisting that you have to wear
a mask to protect yourself
again you want to say you have to wear a
mask in close quarters to protect other
people that's okay but let's not
overestimate what it is the masks do
especially because again we're seeing
spikes
nearly everywhere and there's this
baseline assumption by people on the
left that fulfill
their sort of quasi-paganistic mandates
to do x y or z you won't get covered and
that just isn't true i know a lot of
people who mask up regularly and many of
them have gotten covered
okay that is the covid is easy to obtain
and it doesn't take but one moment
of you removing your mask or of you
breathing in
through a mask in an area that has
already been contaminated to put you
in a bad position so try to stay
outdoors if you can
okay so this does bring up a bigger
question why is it that so many members
of the left
are talking about you know these sorts
of things
while not even following the rules
themselves right we now know that in
california a state that is mandating
mass squaring nearly everywhere right
really everywhere
we now know that not only did gavin
newsom the governor go to an opulent
birthday dinner at the french laundry
restaurant
he was joined by officials from the
california medical association
so let me ask you this do you think that
the officials at the california medical
association
do you think those people were there
because they thought it was wildly
unsafe
or do you think they were using the sort
of differential risk assessment they
deny to you
you're too stupid to determine when you
can be in contact with other people
you're too stupid to determine whether
you can have a thanksgiving family
dinner with a bunch of people under 30
you are too stupid to actually determine
the course of your own life
the folks at the california medical
association will tell you when you can
and cannot meet with people
and get together and go to work but they
themselves will go to a restaurant and
eat in close
proximity indoors with gavin newsom yes
i definitely trust these people to set
the standards there's no hypocrisy here
whatsoever i'm sorry but the the idea
that the folks and blue states know what
they're doing and the folks in red
states just don't know what they're
doing
there's no evidence that this is the
case like whatsoever
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content